my wife and I were professors at
Evergreen for 15 years and Heather was
literally the college's most popular
Professor I wasn't terribly far behind
we had a really dedicated group of
students who went back and forth between
our our programs and because of the way
Evergreen worked
we knew our students extremely well we
could go into the field with them for
weeks at a time was a great place
and on May 23 2017 50 students that I
had never met before streamed into the
building where I was teaching chanting
my name demanding that I'd be fired or
resign
and their accusation was that I was a
racist
an idea that they had actually picked up
from some faculty members who didn't
like me very much because I stood in the
way of their attempt to change the
college which would have been a threat
to the college if it had happened and
and I said so in faculty meetings and
then when that became impossible I said
so over email
in any case that protest
became
violent it descended into violence over
the course of a couple days and the
protesters
made the mistake of filming everything
they did and then uploading it I think
they uploaded it to Facebook but it was
later put on YouTube by somebody who
wanted the world to see it and when the
world did see these students confronting
me something was clearly off so the
incident did not work out the way they
had hoped that it would
um and that catapulted me into the
public eye we
requested demanded and then initiated
the process of suing the college because
they had obviously created an unsafe
working environment
students the president of the college
who in some ways had triggered this
whole episode
ordered the police who were
subordinate to him to stay out of the
conflict between students and us and the
students created a a patrol they
wandered the campus with baseball bats
they actually battered another student
they were looking for me stopping
traffic searching cars this sort of
thing to put things in perspective this
is 2017 27 right yeah were these
students within the school or they just
came out of the Woodworks to show up at
the school these were very definitely
students at the school and uh so you
know this was of course
Downstream of a A diversity equity and
inclusion movement that had become quite
powerful the school was a very liberal
place and so it's not surprising that we
would have seen such a movement
and the problem is that the the policy
changes at the college that that
movement wanted to initiate would have
destroyed the place they were going to
be lethal to its functioning and it was
my obligation as a faculty member to
point that out to be fair but
politically are you a uh uh a pro-trump
supporter Mega guy because if they're
doing that to you you must be a big
supporter of trump well they might think
so yeah I describe myself as a reluctant
radical and the reason I say reluctant
radical is that I believe after many
years of studying the question that our
civilization can't really continue this
way that what we've done has been
brilliant there's of course been lots of
Carnage but our system is not
sustainable in the way it currently
exists and so it has to be retooled for
Humanity to continue to prosper but
so that's the part that makes me a
radical is that I believe only radical
change can save us but I also know that
if you take a system that functions and
our system does function and you alter
it you are very likely to do harm and
you are very likely in your solution
making to bring about unintended
consequences which can be disastrous so
I am a a progressive but I am one with
trepidations about change and and uh
anyway no I'm not not a trump supporter
um I I'm also not a Biden supporter
wasn't a Clinton supporter I believe we
need to find a new Direction well you're
like a Bernie Sanders supporter at some
point I was I am no longer
um I I think that Bernie did represent a
uh a actual challenge to the power
structure that has us locked into this
bad trajectory
um but I think he's he's lost his way
that said even when I was a supporter of
his I wasn't overly convinced that he
understood what direction we needed to
go but he did represent the possibility
of breaking out of the death spiral that
I see our duopoly is having uh speaking
of uh speaking of duopoly would you say
over the last five years since 2017
you've had to do more mental wrestling
with who you identify with more than
ever in your life politically speaking
no because
2017 is not where these questions uh
arrived on my desk at first I've been
thinking about the question of how
civilization functions as an
evolutionary biologist
I was a member of the game B movement
which was a small group of people who
were interested in complex systems and
interested in figuring out what the next
phase of civilization should look like
so I had done a lot of thinking about it
and
frankly I think people make a mistake
they they tend to affiliate
with people and adopt their ideology and
my sense is that ideology is a problem
especially if you pick it up because of
the people who hold it
so my sense is even if there was nobody
else on Earth who agreed with me
that we have to change the way
civilization functions
right I would still be a progressive by
the technical definition because I still
believe we have to alter things if we're
to do well and and my job is to convince
people that that's true if I'm right or
if I'm not right I have to allow them to
convince me that I've got it wrong and I
will change my position so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]